in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Tim and
Terra are with us hey guys how are you a
free edge
welcome welcome where do you guys live
West Des Moines Iowa Oh fun welcome to
Nashville and all the way down here to
do your debt-free scream yeah I love it
how much have you paid off we've hit up
$140,000 cool how long did this take
seven months Wow
and your range of income during that
time well it started about 40,000 then
went up to 230 in seven months yes okay
explain that I'm an independent claims
consultant mm-hmm so I work in insurance
world a lot of hurricanes hit last year
so basically we took the sacrifice and I
just traveled and non-stop worked we did
whatever it took to get out of debt
yeah okay so you were just gone the
whole you pretty much just wasn't worked
and worked artwork you can't do that
forever but you can do that for seven
months yes and that got you completely
clear so what kind of debt was the 140 I
was a house way to go you guys how old
are you - how are 40 right I go in 40 to
be out of debt and we didn't think we
gave up a year ago yeah and then we did
it and then you just said but I mean you
had the how long you been doing the
claims thing we're doing that for eight
years you know so you kind of knew you
could just take off and be gone a year
and make but you just never could do it
before exactly and we did a lot of other
things also yeah what made you pull the
trigger well a couple years ago we had
some pretty life-changing events happen
I broke my leg and foot I came down with
I got a PE DVT had blood clots in my
lungs cool so it was basically scared us
into a reality of okay we've got to do
something we've got to get out of debt
right now and Tara had problems with the
last two pregnancies and we almost lost
her and the last two kids so I was it
was
a point our life when we said you know
what we can't drag our feet any longer
yeah yeah this is real yeah yeah that's
a wake-up call yeah definitely do it
very cool you guys no payments what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is I'll be going for you yeah
yeah do everything it takes yeah
sacrifices anything you can be weird
don't go out and get all the different
kind of loans you can sacrifice don't go
out to eat beans and rice but really I
mean 90 percent of this is attributed to
just a real change in your income beauty
you're just making this decision yeah to
self deploy yeah in a sense and you guys
have a couple of kids yeah
how many eleven eleven yes so you left
her with 11 kids yes and that was her
sacrifice that's her sacrifice yes yeah
and a whip in a chair and that cuz I
mean this is not like she just did home
by herself with the D no no she's got a
dadgum army she's running it oh yeah
very cool yeah how does it feel Oh feels
amazing was it worth it oh yeah yep
never regret it we did over eight we're
not gonna do it over again no but we
don't we have zero regrets then it was
great well you're completely free yeah
it changes everything when you don't
change your mindset you don't think
about anything the same ever again so
now that you settle back in what would
be the rhythm of your income was it back
to 40 no it's gonna be closer to 100
okay yeah so you can kind of do a little
bit of running out here and there but
not be gone all the time and get your
income up a double where it used to be
exactly yeah okay very cool you'll be
able to hit a lot you got a lot of
college funds to do so to work on Wow
Wow very cool very cool congratulations
you got ink you did you have
cheerleaders yeah we had some couple
couple here and there we had some
basically people calling us crazy this
is normal
got 11 kids people call you crazy I love
it that's great ma'am
that is so great congratulations this is
very very cool so uh how did you get
connected to us ten years ago we went
through Financial Peace University okay
and we that prepared our minds our
habits our spending habits our savings
well her savings my spending No
help me correct my spending so we went
through that and basically that helped
us get to this point well how very very
cool all right well let's get all the
kids gathered in they'll take a minute
to participate in the debt-free scream
we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's retire
inspired book for you that is the next
chapter in your story to be millionaires
now and outrageously generous as you go
along so sometimes I get the criticism
of Dave Ramsey stuff doesn't work with
large families well take a look at this
picture you've been living on a budget
for a while yeah you've been smart but
we just want to knock out that last
little bit and so dad goes crazy for a
year not even a year but seven months
and knocks this right we sold everything
that we could in our house to help thing
you sold well we Oliver furniture no way
yeah y'all sitting on the floor yeah
pretty much
card tables and but it's paid for this
yeah and so now you can now you can
rebuild and whatever else you want in
there that's good just took the whole
family on a camping trip yeah yeah
pretty much in our house Wow and we went
dumpster diving that was another crazy
thing that we did that is crazy yeah
that's over the top yeah you guys are
fun well done Tim and Tara from Des
Moines Iowa
area and the 11 kids the tribe is with
him a hundred and forty thousand dollars
paid off in seven months making 40 up to
230 it's a great story an unusual story
in a wonderful story I'm so proud of
y'all
congratulations count it down let's hear
a debt free scream ready three two one
well done all done oh my goodness that's
fun